This may look like something out of a
horror film but it's actually a glass worm
it's the larval form of a very common
lake insect called the phantom midge
and it's evolved kind of a horrific way to
catch a zooplankton
these centimeter or so long worms ambush their prey
with long articulated bristles that rapidly
unfurl into a catching basket
recently researchers discovered exactly how this
capture mechanism works
they were using  high-speed video to study the
interactions between glass worms and one
of its main prey items water fleas
also known as Daphnia
they found that many
bristles prevent the prey from escaping
including long upper lip hairs that fan out
sideways during the glass worm attack
other researchers had doubted that these
lip hairs could move because
they lack muscle but they might be
powered by the pressure of internal fluids
these videos—shot at up to 8,000 fps—
also allowed the researchers to time the attack
The bristles reached their target in just
14 milliseconds—one of the fastest known strikes
for comparison the mantis shrimp
takes just 4 to 8 milliseconds
the record-holders: trap-jaw
ant's and trap-jaw spiders attack in
less than one millisecond
after the glass worm has its prey safely ensnared
it needs around 40 more milliseconds to retract
and then swallow the prey
but as you can see from this
real-time footage
that's still pretty fast